for the european parliament's newest
members 12 meps from croatia among them
epp representative ivana maletic it must
have felt like the first day at school
the official snapshot a route march
along the corridors papers to sign more
papers to sign keys and cards to take
and an empty workspace yet to be filled
with mountains of files that'll become
her daily business this is really
special day for me it's something
historical and i feel like
i i'm part of very important history but
now we are again at the beginning of new
road and now we have to to become active
croatia a country of 4.2 million people
blessed by adriatic sun hit by the
balkan splits and wars of the 1990s is
the eu's 28th member the first expansion
since romania and bulgaria in 2007. this
is a wonderful day for europe a greater
historical moment for croatia
and the signal of hope
for the future of a strong
united
european union and therefore
dobra doshla ratzka
welcome croatia a mood shared by many in
zagreb despite the dismal indicators in
the eu referendum last year 41 turnout
and the election for the first meps this
year 21
we were always in europe but
it's
it's the balkans and so it's not a very
quiet territory and now when we're in
greater europe we are more sure people
are in this european
kind of mood for several years before so
i think this is very good for especially
for young people they may have to wait
some while the languishing croatian
economy improves the eu's newest entrant
joins greece and spain in the over 50
youth unemployment league we are now
becoming member of of the family big
family so we are going on a big market
and we can
succeed on that market if we are smart
and competitive meantime this is a
moment for the eu to save her another
sign that an achilles heel of modern
europe trouble in the balkans is a thing
of the past